hey how's it goin braces Pippa and
welcome to the scariest first off Hebrew
suggested a game called immersion game
doesn't really look that scary I don't
know I don't know what your brother's
think is scary or not but this ain't it
breath well it's alright I can deal with
a change of pace for one time in my life
I don't have to play this gruesome
horror games I can just enjoy a colorful
and beautiful game ah
no dammit I need to be good get good oh
god oh god what's going on mom
go no oh my god oh my god oh my god
senpai senpai do something step back how
help No aah come on brah that's how we
do it
oh my god Jesus Christ dammit
thank God
oh wait it's something I don't
it's it a horror game or a happy game I
don't it's not a happy game just know
had a happy game I swear to God
disgusting it's like my visits to
Grandma all over again oh oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa stop yeah that's how we do
with half nope
no grandma no no you can't touch me
grandma it's it's so many motions in
this game like rage horror happy [ __ ] I
don't even
aah
ah ah mm oh gee you can't stop me thank
this red dirt [ __ ] you then oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god yes suck my ass senpai
ah [ __ ] me oh oh ah ah yes we're back in
happy land oh happy land happy happy
happy
yes everything is so [ __ ] happy isn't
it oh my god what a [ __ ] that I just do
two Illuminati oh my god
happy happy I'm not so happy happy happy
happy so goddamn hey oh god okay okay
okay
it's okay it's okay Wow I'm a main put
up brah brah boom bada bing bada boom
yes the princess is in another no no no
she's right [ __ ] here
oh god no [ __ ] hell what yeah damn it
no no no grant grandma great-grandma me
please no no hentai grandma please no
hentai
ah come on it just quits
what next game we already played but it
got updated so let's check it out I
guess ah here we are back in mounts
mainstream I remember this game was
[ __ ] scary I don't like this hello
this is not how it started last time
radio I could use that yay my radio ran
out of radio I hear something oh god oh
god oh god my prey the radio I just
wanted to play the radio mom this game
is not scary
skip only [ __ ] get scared I never get
scared what am i doing on this boat
let's see here where the [ __ ] was that I
need to find a way out of here
well then Matt a jumpring okay we're
going to the bottom of this
he's far away now we're safe I'm scared
pants I'm scared
shut up your ghosting oh god my [ __ ]
oh god this esteem is sistine no no I
can't - [ __ ] me
oh god it's [ __ ] noises back ah ah my
nip just exploded
what stop stop I might want to go go I
don't be anymore
Oh flash a fleshie to be fleshy gonna
find my baby gonna hold her tight gonna
wrap SMAP new oh god little thinning in
it in it in it we're fine
[ __ ] hell this book what helicopter
does it work dang big function I need to
find keys
fuel pump
holiday and up here in the first place
is probably a better quiz oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
okay you can't get me okay okay let's
throw the coffee like that and YouTube
and YouTube oh god oh god did it work
oh god he's on this Lord oh oh oh oh oh
rah rah rah rah rah rah Oh God yeah hide
it hide hide
yes awesome
look at my lips my nips are amazing
allow mr. monster why'd you go mr.
monster ah what that ain't fair man that
ain't a man I didn't know I didn't know
you won't - bro oh god oh god this is
hide hide hide hide hide hide woman hide
woman yes that that that that that we
did it last game of this evening Bros is
gonna be a good one cos you brother me I
saved the best for last
hey it's a me Mario I'm swimming into
space
a mommy I was the spaghetti where's the
spy your meatballs
there's the key how do I grab it
he said the Kea nailed it you are
invincible now thanks I love being
invincible oh god I can run super fast
yeah yeah look at that I basically
became sanic this game ever finites
Achebe's this game ever girl oh oh it's
like a it's like I have four nights of
Freddy's but you can move oh my god
that's amazing Wow
oh I can look at the cams while I walk
that's a pretty oh god opponents there
you gotta get gotta go fast I guess
minecraft King no no no anyone anyone
with Minecraft King huh oh if nuts will
see this eyes would tell notch about
this and he was good up I'm not scared
of Oh
I got a pony
ah what the [ __ ] Mike black bra yeah
vote right now which one you thought
would spookiest and I will laugh and
we'll see in the next one he was
watching Stacey awesome
oh oh hello oh I'm sorry
they get you from the love of God on the
hey hey check them